hey guys merry here for gamespot's the
mix at e3 2015 i'm here with ian gregory
oh yes of course and you are from
witching hour studios and you're here to
show us masquerade songs in shadow
that's right so masquerade is a 2.5 g
isometric RPG it's based very much on
things like ball this Gator never win
tonight's we love combat that's strong
and very big on story as well so that's
what we're trying to do mm-hmm we're
also building a whole new world where in
this world magic is only possible by the
use of masks so a very big part is
collecting these masks and figuring out
what they do and what they're all about
and if you notice you can actually pause
the game at any point very much like the
old infinity engine games and give
instructions and if you saw that you can
kind of play it live like this well it
seems like there's a lot of inspiration
from various these types of games or you
feel like a little bit of a Dungeons and
Dragons vibe from it can you tell me
you're you're in the middle of the story
right we're not starting this at the
beginning right so where are we right
now so right now your displays this
location called the cleaver and what
you're trying to do is actually find
clues because the game starts out
there's a bit of a whodunit you're
looking for a missing person and you're
kind of going down one of the path to
figure out where he's going and what
he's trying to do spends a lot of story
and dialogue and you can see they all
wear masks at all times and we're
playing with the masks and Matsu levels
with regards to gameplay but also a
story as well and hiding what just what
what you feel and what you're all about
and the main characters all have very
strong care talks that we want to
explore as well okay so when you
exchange your mask that gives you
various abilities or actually changes
the gameplay mentally so the mocks give
the mosque give you a major type
learning spell but more anything else it
allows you access to an element that you
can use the fight so when you enter the
game you actually get to choose an
element from which you play with and
each one has a different style the main
character Cicero he is our unique class
he's called a minstrel and he's allowed
to use skills from all the other classes
so as a player you do get to experiment
and figure out what you like to do okay
and so yeah you get all these options
right from the get-go like what kind of
player you actually want to be
but now because you are you're in a
group and you're playing multiple
characters yes you play upon all right
so in your party you can kind of mix and
match and get to explore various types
of characters and battles where there
you want to be like a melee character
yeah that's right no there's also a
tagging system so if you have different
elements and you hit the enemy with
different things you causes effects it
can stand them you can slow them down
and things like that so there's a bit of
tactical play as well so you can pause
and actually use things in intended with
each other to create interesting effects
mm-hmm and there's obviously a lot of
inspiration from various games but one
we can't deny it for stopping time here
might be a little bit of transistor yes
it sounds like you might be inspired by
transistor very much you know the
transistor system of pausing and being
able to actually think about what you
want to do is that was it's very big
part of what we're trying to accomplish
there's also the matter of like the way
the skills work you know because you
hold it you have a party and you want to
be able to combo stuff as well so
definitely the pausing will definitely
help that alright so where we at right
now it looks like we have three party
members and we're just kind of exploring
this new area yes so this is the
crossroads this is actually one the
major fights before one of them smaller
bosses that you'll meet and you'll
notice that the fights are kind of set
up like a set piece so you go in and you
fight it's suppose to be a nice proper
fight rather than you know just running
down and just killing one two things
every little while so you're going to
really think about it and what we're
hoping to do in the long term is to make
every fight few like a puzzle one by
itself to try and figure out how to be
efficient with what the skills that you
have what are the different character
skills currently so for example it was a
sweet pea right day of like a little ice
water move yeah and then you can she
pull them into the void and then don't
you know they'll take damage when hit
the wall what she's about to do is
called a fissure where she leaves a
trail of lava behind it when they
traverse it they're gonna get hit so if
you overlay abilities one over the other
you can be quite efficient with how
you're taking down the enemy as well and
if you notice that rings on the ground
so direction actually met this if you
hit something from the back you're going
to bypass the harm oh dear shields and
things like that okay yeah so you can
your there's a lot of strategy involved
in how you attack your enemies from what
area what position the timing who goes
up against who I like the idea of being
able to yeah
up your enemies and then kind of slash
them all at once yeah you know do
technical things like where you're
taking away areas they can walk yeah by
putting things on the ground so there's
all sorts of elements here what what
else will you expect these people to be
able to gain as the story progresses
right so one of the big things is that
we are foregoing XP all together so it's
not as though you're just going to be
collecting points as you progress your
story will be giving skill points which
you can use to change your abilities so
it's not just you know adding more
damage than ability its function can
change quite drastically so one of the
abilities accessible has is that he can
actually teleport and if you choose this
air and so if you want to play
offensively you can actually have him
like blast hot air where he appears next
on defensively he can actually blast
cold air to where he was so that he can
get away from the enemy so we would both
have this both have the same ability by
wood functions so differently as you
could progress through the game okay so
yeah and then that's gonna continue to
elevate and change the gameplay up as
you continue to go on now we're in the
boss it is a small boss fight this is a
small boss fight it gets worse it feels
big to me but yeah so this is just one
of the smaller bosses in the fight and
do they drop anything when they when you
take them down no so they don't but what
they actually do is I can progress the
story suggests there are reasons why
you're fighting these things and that's
a great big power what's going on you
also notice that all the backgrounds are
painted so what we're actually doing is
the opposite of what most games do so we
actually have 3d characters traversing a
2d world the hope is that whenever you
pause the game it feels as though you're
you know playing through a comic book
and then later as we get more as we go
further down development we're gonna
have comic panels as well I love the
color platter if you notice it comes
from a french comic book style or very
offbeat you know it's otherworldly
although it's very believable with
regard to our eternity yeah it's
absolutely stunning and it's the art
direction they've done a really good job
with detail from the painting of the
backgrounds which seems not too much
detail because the last thing you want
is to get distracted from the gameplay
at hand right so you've put most of the
effort into the effects and stuff but
the the painted backgrounds are very
calming and enjoyable and serene and
that's a huge help and when you're
making a game visually you know you
don't you don't want to overcome
k things definitely yeah I mean in the
undie it needs to serve the experience
instead of trying to say that you know
we've got amazing graphics is more like
the graphics make the game that much
better it's about elevating it and
that's that's one of the things that we
talk about a lot in the office we're
trying to push the boundary of what we
trying to do we previously we didn't
mobile game so this is a big jump for us
this is huge jump for you guys
especially for is like a smaller team
it's a 15 you said about him yeah
working on this in support yeah it's
kinda like a midsize to do in singapore
it's y'all be on the other side of the
world and this is the kind of game that
you might expect your conference
singapore as well yes that is true you
know in singapore it's mostly about our
efficiency so smaller teams making games
that has the higher potential revenue is
a big thing right but we believe that
games are as much hot as it is a
business so we try to push the
boundaries which regards forward to what
we're trying to do this about research
behind what we what we like and we all
game is so we're kind of like making
games for ourselves by the extent i mean
that's the beauty of being an indie it
is it's like the the true art of an
indie right is that you're not doing it
for profit but for the sheer sake of
make a nice profit would be good to use
by the game guys let me be clear uh we
also enjoy profit yes but we definitely
do enjoy making something that we can be
proud of and we are especially that
direction what i want it very clearly
was something that could be timeless you
could play this ten years down the road
and not feel as though its data so you
know if we push the boundaries on it on
the on the graphics too hard right you
get uncanny valley yeah but you want to
avoid so we go stylized we want
something that you know you're gonna
look at it it's gonna be timeless it's
like a Disney movie it's absolutely time
and it's absolutely stunning and thank
you so much for so much money that was
masquerader songs and shadows you check
that out and for all your other gaming
news be sure to head to gamespot com